[Music]
on this monday night
breaking news bill morneau is no longer
finance minister
did he quit or was he forced out
how hackers compromised the personal
data of thousands of canadians
there were two payments of serb applied
in my behalf
and then my direct deposit information
had been changed
should more be done to secure sensitive
information
are you eager to reunite with friends
and relatives in the u.s
air canada promotes flying to america
despite the rising cases
south of the border the explosive rape
allegations against canadian fashion
mogul peter nygaard
made by his sons and seasons sidelined
the pandemic forces the cfl to punt its
season
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with breaking news bill marneau
is out as canada's finance minister
late today mourinho resigned effective
immediately saying the time is right
for someone else to take over the reins
of the economy there has been
controversy surrounding the former
finance minister with his ties
to we charity and there has been tension
between him
and the prime minister of course this is
all happening in the middle of a
pandemic
and an economic crisis i had a
constructive conversation with the prime
minister this morning
we have always worked together over the
course the last five years
in a way that recognized the importance
of vigorous discussion and debate
to get to the best policies for
canadians i'm proud of what we've done
over the last five years
working to make sure that we have a more
inclusive economy that we have a greener
economy
and i know that work will continue
let's bring in our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson mercedes
bill morneau insists he quit but the
seems sudden and who quits in the middle
of a pandemic so
was he forced out well that is the
question and it's pretty extraordinary
when you think about it robin we are in
the middle of a massive financial crisis
in this country
and at this moment there is no finance
minister
for a finance minister to suddenly
decide to step down
while he was citing his decision not to
run in the next election even though
that election at this point
is nowhere in sight is very odd
on top of that you have the events that
you described surrounding this
you have the reports in the press of the
public disagreements between the prime
minister
and the finance minister and then you
have the developments with the we
charity which
surprised the pmo and left the prime
minister's office
and the prime minister very angry those
revelations that bill morneau's daughter
was working there
and that he in fact still had to pay
back 41 000
for a trip he took with we all of that
was building to rumors that mourinho
would not survive
mourinho insists it was his decision to
tender his resignation to the prime
minister this morning
but obviously the timing on this is
nothing short of extraordinary
and highly unusual given the typical
desire would be for stability
during this kind of a situation but
mercedes the prime minister is also
being investigated
there's an ethics investigation
involving him when it comes to we
charity so did mourinho take the fall
for this
well that's the question is that folks
thought he was going to take the fall he
insists that's not the case
but at the same time there were certain
omissions in his statements
which implied that that there was
certainly a link
to what happened with we he didn't deny
that that may have played a role he said
that there have been vigorous debates
between he and the prime minister at
times
but when you look at this and step back
it was very well choreographed by the
prime minister's office and the finance
minister
to appear that he had tendered his
resignation with the intention of going
to run
to be the secretary general of the oecd
which is a plum post
so it appears trudeau is still still
supporting him as he leaves his job
uh but it doesn't change the fact that
the timing on this is all very odd
and that a lot of political sources
thought that if trudeau wanted to turn
the page
to move forward he may have to get rid
of mourinho and that they simply did not
have the same financial vision for the
country
in terms of spending and in terms of the
direction that they wanted canada to go
in
as for the prime minister he did issue a
statement saying i have counted on his
leadership advice and close friendship
over the years
and i look forward to that continuing
well into the future
bill you have my deepest gratitude and i
know you will continue making great
contributions to our country
and for canadians in the years to come
and as you mentioned the prime minister
did add he supports moreno's bid to seek
the leadership of the organization for
economic cooperation and development
so who's going to step into the finance
job
well robin tonight global news can
inform our viewers that we have learned
it's not
mark carney there was a lot of
speculation that that's who it was going
to be
he of course is the very well-liked and
charismatic former governor of the bank
of canada also
former governor of the bank of england
and there was rumors out there which
were then substantiated and found to be
true that the prime minister in fact had
been talking to mr carney and getting
his advice and people suggested
that was a sign of his lack of
confidence in bill morneau and perhaps a
trial balloon going up to see if kearney
would take over
it would be highly unusual to have an
unelected finance minister
so in this case we can tell you that a
senior government sources told global
news
mark carney is not in the running and he
is busy with the united nations
not looking to take over there was also
speculation when morneau stepped down
as an mp as well as finance minister it
was making space for kearney
that doesn't appear to be what's going
on at least at this point
there's a couple of names on that list
minister duklow
someone who could move into that with a
financial background christian freeland
potentially
canada has never had a female minister
of finance
or uh minister champagne who right now
is serving in foreign affairs and has a
strong finance background as well
we still don't know when or who it's
going to be
so we're in the highly unusual situation
tonight of canada having no finance
minister
lots more to come tomorrow i'm sure al
zavois thanks for your insight mercedes
stephenson in ottawa
to the other big story in ottawa an rcmp
investigation is underway after a series
of cyber attacks forced the shutdown
of the canada revenue agency website
this past weekend officials revealed
hackers had breached
thousands of accounts for the cra and up
to 30
other federal departments the government
says a big part of the problem is that
many people had been reusing passports
but as abigail beeman explains experts
say there's more the government can
and should be doing it was very
stressful i was worried that it was more
than just my account that was hacked
was my identity julie kagansky got this
email from the cra saying her serb
application had been processed and her
banking information
changed the thing is she never applied
for the serb
the individual told me i would receive a
call from them in 24 hours
and i still haven't received a call with
further
instructions that was a week ago
officials now describe what happened as
credential stuffing credential stuffing
is all about
trying to have bots going out there and
searching for usernames and passwords
that
people are using in different
applications from ordering your pizza
to filing your taxes to actually having
it as your facebook account
it affected about 11 000 accounts at the
cra but also my gc key accounts used
across 30 government departments
officials have been working with the
rcmp since august 11
but only took questions today and seemed
to put the blame
squarely on canadians the credentials
used in the attack came from previous
non-government of canada data breaches
they were effective because canadians
reused old passwords use a different
password on every website and change it
frequently
canadians are strongly encouraged to
avoid reusing passwords
they did admit to one problem on their
end a now fixed vulnerability that
allowed hackers to bypass cra security
questions
certainly we apologize for any
inconvenience on behalf the government
of canada that caused to any of our
clients the responsibility
can't just be on actual canadians
the government should take you know
appropriate
measures and changes an important
measure say the experts
multi-factor authentication the
government agrees but says
implementing it is a challenge some
two-factor
authentication systems would have
prevented this
the cra is aiming for the portal to be
back online wednesday and says people
can apply for the serb
by phone in the meantime but officials
are urging anyone
impacted by the hack to check other
accounts online banking
social media and again to change your
passwords
robin abigail beeman in ottawa
the battle against coven 19 in alberta
and british columbia
isn't going the way public health
officials were hoping
in the last 72 hours alberta has
recorded 359
new positive tests for the novel
coronavirus while bc is reporting 236
new cases
in the three-day period since friday and
it was revealed today
teachers and students in that province's
schools will have to wear non-medical
face masks on buses
in common areas and in situations where
physical distancing
isn't possible mask requirements class
sizes and protocols for handling an
outbreak
these are all lingering concerns for
parents and teachers alike
provincial and territorial governments
are hammering out their back to school
strategies
but as heather york's west reports it's
a patchwork of plans
right across the country shelly dyer is
about to head back to class
the brampton ontario teacher knows
she'll be teaching grade 8
this year but beyond that she has many
questions about what her school will be
like
under the threat of covet 19. class
sizes we have no idea
set up in the physical classrooms we
have no idea
logistical stuff like entry exit how
they're going to do staggered lunches
those sort of details we have no idea
that's because with just
three weeks until classes resume back to
school plans are still
very much taking shape in toronto public
health officials have started recruiting
more than 70 nurses to help city schools
navigate the year ahead these nurses
will provide education and training
sessions to
school staff to parents and caregivers
to promote
infection prevention and control
measures and
other public health advice so as to
limit opportunities for the covet 19
virus
to spread it seems no two school
districts are handling the school year
the same in calgary even kindergarten
age
students will be required to wear a mask
i know my kids like touch everything now
they're going to be touching their faces
touching the masks and that's going to
become like a germ
vest on their masks but this infectious
diseases physician believes it might be
time
for everyone to take a breath when we
take a step back and look at
the thirty thousand foot view it's clear
that all
provinces are really integrating the
same fundamental public health
principles into their back to school
plan
teachers like dyer just want to know how
physical distancing
ventilation masks testing and tracing
will work for her classroom in only a
few weeks time
heather urex west global news calgary
a new brunswick doctor who didn't
self-isolate after a trip to quebec and
later tested positive for coveted 19
has been charged under the province's
emergency measures act
he could be fined up to ten thousand
dollars the province suspended dr
jean-jorbe nagola after linking him to
an outbreak in campbellton
in may 41 people tested positive for
covet 19
two people died the fifth-year-old says
he traveled to quebec to pick up his
daughter
and immediately returned home but he
continued seeing
patients nagola's lawyer claims he has
evidence showing his client is not to
blame for the outbreak
and is seeking an apology from the
premier the lawyer says nagola who is
originally from the democratic republic
of the congo
has been subject to racism and threats
on social media
pressure is mounting on belarus's
president alexander lukashenko
to step down over accusations this
month's election
was rigged
[Applause]
the president was met by angry workers
during a visit at a factory in minsk
today
during his speech lukashenko said there
would be no new election
but he did offer to change the
constitution tens of thousands of people
across the country
have been protesting the election
results that handed lukashenko
a sixth term this is the biggest
challenge the leader has faced in his 26
years
in office explosive allegations coming
up
the lawsuit filed against canadian
fashion mogul peter nygaard
by two of his sons
a major multi-million dollar settlement
has been reached over police tactics
during the 2010 g-20 summit in toronto
the toronto police board has agreed to
pay out 16.5
million dollars to hundreds of
protesters and others who were rounded
up
and detained during the summit as part
of the settlement those arrested will be
entitled to between
five thousand dollars and just over
twenty four thousand dollars
depending on their treatment by police
the agreement must still be approved
by a judge there are some stunning new
allegations against former fashion mogul
peter
nygaard after being accused of sexual
assault by more than 50 women
he's now facing accusations from two of
his own sons
global's kevin hirschfield joins me now
from nygard's hometown of winnipeg kevin
what can you tell us well robin the
allegations continue to mount against
winnipeg fashion mogul peter nygaard who
is facing another lawsuit
his latest accusers two of his sons
in the latest lawsuit the sons allege
their father ordered his girlfriend who
the suit claims is a full-time sex
worker
to statutorily rape them 14 years apart
when they were teenagers
the first complainant alleges nygard's
son was flown from california
to nightguard's winnipeg home in 2018 at
14 years old
where nygard orchestrated the alleged
rape to quote
make a man out of him according to the
court documents
but the accusations state this wasn't
the first time nygaard had arranged the
alleged rape of one of his sons
in 2004 he's accused of instructing the
same woman to have sex with his other
son
who was allegedly 15 at the time at a
beachfront property in the bahamas
now one of nygard's lawyers jay prober
says his client denies the allegations
peter nygard believes this is part of
the continued
conspiracy against him and part of the
continued
publicity campaign against him nygard
has already been accused of sexual
assault by 57 women in a separate class
action lawsuit
none of the accusations in either
lawsuit have been proven in court
and nygard claims it is a conspiracy and
publicity campaign
against him robin kevin hirschfield in
winnipeg
still ahead in a time when it's
important to stay in why are airlines
urging canadians
to fly out
you're watching global national
[Music]
the canada u.s border remains closed to
all non-essential travel
until at least september 21st but some
travelers have been taking advantage of
a loophole that allows them to fly
back and forth and as shawn o'shea
reports one canadian airline is even
promoting this kind of travel at
toronto's pearson international known as
canada's busiest
airport passenger terminals haven't been
crowded for five months
many medical experts say that's a good
thing we're in the middle of a pandemic
we need to keep that border closed
until you know it's safe to open and
right now it's not safe to open
and while the land border to the united
states is restricted to all but
essential travel
you can legally fly to the united states
for leisure travel if you like
they even tell you how to do it are you
eager to reunite with friends and
relatives in the u.s
did you know that canadians are
permitted to travel by
air to and from the us for leisure or
business
probably should be some social
responsibility here is in the sense that
the borders closed for non-essential
travel but not
being advertising non-essential travel
the government of canada still advises
against all non-essential travel outside
the country
and where the u.s is concerned some
experts say caution is especially
important
i mean going to an area with lots of
community transmission
of kova 19 where you're going to be in
contact with other people
i would advise against that air canada
says it's offering essential services
and allowing families to reunite the
company also told global news in a
statement that it follows
all federal rules and has put in place
industry-leading bio safety measures
to protect customers and employees the
airline industry association wants the
government to consider allowing more
travel
to countries where the virus is under
control jill murphy is traveling to
boston to visit her ailing grandmother
people don't have to go then there's
nothing there's no reason to go to a
place that
doesn't have the greatest of safety
recommendations right now she says
she'd rather stay home and can't
understand why anyone would plan a
pleasure trip south
during a pandemic sean o'shea global
news toronto
up next canadian football is officially
hunted by the pandemic
hopes have been dashed for canadian
football fans the cfl season has been
officially called
off and for the first time in 100 years
there will be no grey cup
the league asked ottawa for a loan to
make up for the hit it's taking from
lost ticket sales
because of the kovan 19 pandemic but as
eric sorensen reports
the federal government didn't play ball
it is a canadian institution it has
played in the mud and the snow
it has seen franchises come and go and
come back again
it has lost money consistently and yet
the canadian football league has played
through it all
until now with refurbished facilities
like lansdowne park in ottawa the league
is so dependent on gate revenue
that it couldn't face the financial
losses if the gates are closed
because of the pandemic the cfl at first
wanted more than a hundred million
dollars from ottawa
a follow-up request for a 30 million
dollar loan through the business
development bank also did not come
through
the problem is that there was no
business plan how is it that every other
professional sports league has managed
to somehow come up with a plan
and an attempt uh and push ahead this
league was cancelled
because of financial reasons it wasn't
even canceled for health reasons
in a statement the league's president
said even with additional support
our owners and community-held teams
would have had to endure
significant financial losses to play in
2020.
in its own statement ottawa said it
helped the cfl navigate
covet 19 emergency response programs
that are helping tens of thousands of
businesses across canada
adding it was the cfl that ultimately
made the decision
not to pursue the upcoming season it's
more than a league
the cfl is a part of canada commissioner
randy ambrosi has tried to cement the
cfl as an essential part of the
country's culture
the fans have been the most diehard in
canadian sport the league hoped to play
a shortened season in a bubble in
winnipeg this fall
now for the first time since 1919 there
will be no grey cup game
the cfl says it's committed to next
season and the hope is
fans will miss the game and come back in
full force in 2021
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the hamlet of
dewinton alberta
just south of calgary we'd love to see
your corner of this country so please
send your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night